friends there's a
there's a wonderful thinker
his name is David Deutsch he wrote the
fabric of reality and he wrote the
beginning
of infinity and he has a TED Talk that
is a grand summation of his ideas of his
Earth shattering Vision it's called
chemical scum that dream of distant
quasars
it's a shattering world view
increasingly it has become in Vogue to
dismiss Humanity as merely chemical scum
a pale blue dot suspended in a Sunbeam
we are nothing we are but a grain of
sand in Infinity we are something to be
dismissed nothing but chemical scum in a
cosmos of such scale that it simply
reduces us to the a kind of cosmic Ash
of nothing
but David Deutsch he has a different
point of view on what we are he calls us
chemical scum that dream of distant
quasars and it is precisely our capacity
to dream of different quasars that makes
us different but it starts not there it
starts actually
with the following idea
in the early
universe everything we can see when we
aim our space telescopes into the past
in the early universe
big things
dumb big things affect Little Things
Stars affect planets and so on and so
forth big dumb things affect small
insignificant things
except for us
see life is different
the beginning of Life was where suddenly
little things could now affect big
things
the beginning of Life and what became
photosynthesis meant that suddenly
plants could change the surfaces and
compositions of a planet small things
could now change big things
the emergence of humanity the harnessing
of energy increasingly sophisticated
means to harness energy means that small
things like us can now affect big things
nuclear
power being but one example Interstellar
travel but yet another example mining
asteroids
nanotechnology increasingly little
things can affect big things and the
destiny of the universe inevitably is
exponential Technologies continue to
compound and we can increasingly shape
matter the world becomes subject to our
willed intent the cosmos becomes a
programmable medium it is a kind of
Omega point that Pierre de Chardon spoke
about or a technological singularity the
point is and David Deutsch writes about
this in the beginning of infinity is
that if you look at the Topography of
the city the Topography of a city is
shaped more by mind creativity and
intentionality than by geology
the analogy is clear increasingly mind
the compositions the chemical scum that
makes up our mind can shape star systems
little things can now shape big things
so the chemical scum the dream of
distant quasars have a role to play
in the universe
we can orchestrate the songs that sing
the universe as Marshall mcluhan wrote I
think that's a very optimistic narrative
because it invites us to look beyond
what Edward O Wilson described as our
Paleolithic brains at our medieval laws
because we have in fact as he says
Godlike Technologies and so the destiny
of our species ultimately is to spawn
Infinity an intelligence explosion a
creativity turning itself inside out the
imagination summoning its own
literalization this is the scale of
impact in which David Deutsch invites us
to participate in what a reason to get
out of bed in the morning to become star
makers to become imagineers to become
star makers to become imagineers this is
our Interstellar destiny
the chemical scum the dream of distant
quasars were about to render ourselves
whole and then render ourselves holy
and impregnate the cosmos with mind
thank you David Deutsch for your
ambition thank you you for listening let
us
let us do this friend let us stand up
for what is now possible
let us have the cosmic ambition let us
have the audacity
for our imagination to summon its own
literalization
this friends is what David Deutsch calls
the beginning
of infinity